well Gary is a very smart man and he's
done a lot of great things there he was
a good outreach to the business
community he understood the issues very
well there's lots of other very
qualified people there the key is being
able to keep a balanced team around the
president that he trusts and can listen
to so whenever anything whenever someone
leaves no one individually is
irreplaceable but it's difficult cuz you
have to replace that trust he's built it
up over the positive tax deal that
happened and working with him and he'll
find someone else I'm sure who will come
in but Gary is a very smart man whose
voice will be missed I think from the
business community's perspective and the
White House so the big tool the big
conversation right now in geopolitics is
president Trump's imposition of
aluminium and steel tariffs what have
you made of that well obviously there's
lots of worry around the world about
where this leads I think more than the
actual tariffs themselves that aluminum
and steel we've had that before in the
United States President Bush and maybe
even President Obama they're in their
own right not going to disrupt global
economies but really people are worried
is this the beginning of a tit for tat
is this the beginning of protectionist
attitudes and where does this spiral -
and how does that result in affecting
negotiations around chorus and after and
other trade deals so - really worrisome
as to where this goes for a
protectionist standpoint as much as the
terrorists themselves President Trump
has already said he's going to impose
high tariffs on you you car imports
should be go ahead with retaliatory
measures I mean just how close are we in
your opinion to a full blown trade war
well this is what's really important
when you have rhetoric like this that is
is really going on and we haven't even
seen the underlying policies yet you
have to somehow ignore the noise and
focus on the actual what happens here so
I would hate to see rhetoric boil up so
much people start doing things based on
that some of this could be negotiating
tactics some of this could be real
problem issues that have to be dealt
with in making fairer trade deals or
some of it you know could be foundation
for future agreements as you say
president george w bush under under who
you served President Obama they both
impose tariffs at various points in
their administrations what's Trump doing
differently from them there's a lot of
you know this income inequality that's
happened the loss of jobs due to
technology and there's some blaming of
global trade for factories being shut
down and so a lot of people came out and
voted and said we want you to think
about us within your borders not just
the global arena president ran on that
and I think he's following through
what's clear is and he said this many
times he's not against trade deals he's
not against global trade he wants the
trade deals updated he wants some fairer
and obviously the fairer is in the eye
of the beholder between the negotiators
at the table on trade deals so what
you're seeing is him challenging all
these deals what we haven't seen yet is
how these issues are going to be
resolved um the Orang is this rabbit
heiress comes just weeks after President
Trump cut taxes for a lot of you your
American corporates obviously that did a
great deal of good he's blotted his
copybook here with American business
hasn't it to an extent well yeah the
president's been very clear that you
know he's looking at American workers
not just through the eyes of business
and and he believes in this situation
American workers have struggled under
these unfair trade deals that have in
his eyes have been out there but
undoubtedly the tax bill great provided
liquidity and great confidence for
investing in the United States the
uncertainty around these trade issues
and what effect they could have on the
pricing of goods and coming into the
factories in the United States certainly
puts an uncertainty tax there at offset
some of the benefit of the of the tax
bill and what's your perspective on the
brexit situation right now well here in
Ireland obviously where I'm at brexit is
a very big deal across Europe it's a big
deal and from investors in the US and in
the rest of the world it's a big deal we
have clients all over who are trying to
get certainty we just talked about the
uncertainty tax that's out there the
uncertainty of how brexit will end up
whether or not they're going to have
access to the European market and
whether or not people can move freely
back and forth we have some 15,000
people in the UK many coming
from the EU wondering what their futures
going to be and from a business
standpoint though the sooner they can
resolve the big issues the sooner we can
move forward with certainty as to where
and how to invest that will be a benefit
for both the UK and for broader Europe